what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here today to do our
use our Monday use which is to watch from our
friend Paul the heavy spoilers The Last of Us
episode three he sticks breakdown reaction I
think I sound just like it I almost thought
you were him for I was about to say oh yeah but
don't make an ass out of you or me Greg okay
Theory time theory time very time all right
guys we'll leave a like if you haven't seen
her episode three reaction it's up here on the
Chanel right now John and Terrors will be up man
Yana that means tomorrow in Spanish right that
means tomorrow and Pedro Pascal let's get to it
[Music] now the first thing I want to do is
go through Belle's story in the PlayStation
classic for anyone who hasn't played it this
will kind of give you an idea of just how much
things were changed and what we originally
had first time round as always we will be
saving future spoilers for the end of the
video and if you enjoy it then please hit
the thumbs up button and don't forget
I've already done it done it all done
by the way huge thank you for clicking
this you're welcome are you voicing over
[Music]
in the game you arrive in Lincoln having just
escaped the state building this culminated in
Tessa's death and Joel and Ali fled into the
Subway after being chased by fedra you never
really got to catch your breath and on the
other side of this when you slow down Joe
refused to talk about Tess this showed just how
cold he was and even upon reaching Bill he just
played along that she was alive without ever
correcting him now the way that Joel and Ali
met with him was that they sprung one of his
traps which led a gel being suspended upside
down in one of the tensor scenes in the game
sworn by infected you had to defend yourself
in Ellie as they tried to tear you apart this
is when bill came in and after making your way
to his church you laid low for a beer before
Manning a plan to get a truck battery this was
from a military Caravan that had crashed
into a nearby School in an area that bill
normally refused to go to this was due to that
side of town being teeming with infected but
because the old Joel a favor they decided to
head out there overloaded with infected you
found that the battery had already been taken
and he had to burst you to school before make
Frank who had made a break for it unlike the
show Frank couldn't stand Bill anymore and when
the Caravan crashed he devised the planet take the
battery on the way out though he'd been bitten and
he ended up unaliving himself before the infection
took its toll you see there was something really
interesting about the way it's played out
here where I don't have the TV show right
no the gay man drew the game listen to what I'm
saying sorry sorry I'm saying Andrew it's pretty
much alluded that bill and Frank perhaps were in a
relationship why I say alluded is because it it's
the way it kind of transgresses in the actual
game is it seemed like it was sort of a secret
between Bill and Frank it's not something where
it seemed like their relationship was super open
about it you could have just you know translated
as no they were just friends but they were maybe
secretly gay it didn't seem like they were an
openly gay couple I always interpreted as they
were gay just when he said he was my partner
I know you could take that in in other ways
but that's just how I took in the way he how you
know the the sorrow it's just my homophobia listen
to me listen to the game Greg listen to what the
game is saying sorry no no he's a Catholic I hear
a partner I feel oh business yeah exactly I mean
business if it wasn't a post-apoc alyptic world I
might have probably probably but yeah also too you
could see kind of the sorrow you know and how sad
bill was at when he first saw him and then also
when he got that note like he looked deeply hurt
right so that's that's why I took it that way
he laughed a note behind the bells saying how
much he hated him and after finding his truck you
pop the clutch and headed out to Pittsburgh now
that's the way the game played out with it being
heavily focused on action and a massive deviation
from what we get here I'll be going through How
Stuff compares to the game as we get into it but
that's kind of a bird's eye view of how it plays
out so you can instantly see how different it is
to the show now we begin with Joe dipping his hand
into a river and there's a tension drawn of the
cuts on his knuckles from smashing that God's
face in like a new like button Ellie very much
represents the daughter that he couldn't save and
the lesson that he learned from this is the wrong
one and he might end up thinking that violence is
the way to achieve things I suppose it probably
is the right lesson in this world but he clearly
wrestles with losing his cool like this now this
idea of losing one's control is juxtaposed by
the stone stacking that we see him carrying
out typically you'd see something like this in
a spa and stone stackings carried out because
it has a spiritual connection to the Earth but
also takes time and effort to create the balance
in the pile and this Stone stacking seen as being
something that showcases one's patience however
it goes beyond that and it's a practice that's
being carried out in several cultures dating all
the way back to ancient Mongolia Stone Stacks
were also used for navigation in rural areas
due they're not being signed posts to roads out
in the woods or by Rivers I think it's more for
the former reason but I I just thought I'd bring
that up too but you know it's also ironic Joel is
from Texas and in Texas stacking rocks and Texas
state parks actually isn't allowed so perhaps it
goes in conjunction with him being rebellious
I don't know Texas and stacking rocks isn't
allowed so you know what it goes it stays in the
real rejects reaction to heavy spoilers video as
some type of contribution to this fact about
stacking rocks now that 10 miles outside of
Boston in the woods which is a location that you
start up at before traveling until to Lincoln now
he's now wearing a green coat with a red hoodie
and this is something that she'd done later on
in the game once we hit the winter sections though
Joel's pretty [__] off from her I like the touch
that they've added here which is that she's
using his jacket for a blanket at this point
he's still reeling from the death of Tess but
due to being a close book he refuses to open up
he still clearly cares though and he tosses her
some food which leads into a conversation that
plays out slightly differently in the game they
kind of change up the positioning of the lines
and Joel says not to bring up Tess here whereas
he does it at the end of the episode in the show
hey look um about Tess listen about tests
I don't even know here's how these things
gonna play out you don't bring up tests ever
rule one you don't bring up tests ever exactly
I love these side by sides yeah actually just
keep our histories to ourselves secondly don't
tell anybody about your condition well too you
don't tell anyone about your condition they
think you're crazy they'll try to kill you
you see that bite mark they won't
think it through they'll just shoot you
and lastly you do what I say when I say it
rule three you do what I say when I say it
are we clear we clear repeat it
sure repeat it what you say goes
you see what I loved about seeing this
side-by-side comparison is whatever
actors are doing a scene there's one of the common
terminologies is what is the actor's prior moment
going into it what happened before this scene that
we are doing because that often can be a dictation
of how you're going to be going about your
performance in that currency right even though
the lines are pretty much the exact same way the
placement of it gives it a completely different
prior moment and leading into it so the delivery
from the actors is going to be very different
type of energy and tone and mood while a little
bit similar in some variations of the levels of
course it's also feels like a very different kind
of scene because of how we got to the scene in the
Show versus the exact moments leading up to it in
the game itself so I think having a cool side by
side by like that makes it feel like oh we're
getting like two very different scenes by that
point I know what I mean yeah that's a very good
observation because as you were just saying in
the video game we get to the that moment right
after what happens to Tess whereas in the show
we get to that moment after a lot of traveling
yeah a lot of traveling so they're a little more
calm and they're you know it's not just uh they
had not just been through an emotional ordeal
so it's really cool seeing the side by side and
again what I love about these actors is they're
not imitating they're making it their own as well
but yeah that's a great observation you made thank
you that's why I'm here and also to point out that
in Texas stacking rocks is illegally at the parks
I'll remember that if I ever go there do not
stack right that's the only crime I'm not going
to commit is stacking rocks either way giola is
completely shut off and they hike for four hours
before passing through the woodlands one of the
things that's never really touched upon about the
last of us is how much it focus is on the beauty
of Nature and how once Humanity's been whittled
down the Earth can reclaim the land beautiful
apocalypse but uh cordyceps themselves could very
much be seen as a defense mechanism for Earth
and tying back at the climate change comments
this could be the planet finding a way to get rid
of us without creating Skynet big Theory time for
that but Ellie asks Jill how he got his scar and
he says it's from the early days when someone shot
at him and missed though he says that he shot back
it is possible that this could have come from the
night Sarah died and it may have been a stray
from The Soldier's bullets the scars up beside
his Temple and I think this would explain a lot if
he was reminded of that night every time he looked
in the mirror and they traveled to Cumberland
I thought that was the same thing it's a real
store in America so I learned something about our
cousins every day this is a stash house where gels
Left Behind supplies but the real talking point
here is the Mortal Kombat 2 cabinet Ellie mentions
her friend he knew everything about this game
and this is likely Riley who was touched upon
in episode one I can't tell you how much money
this machine swallowed seriously Park when I was
a kid and me and my cousin Mark used to spend most
of our time on a Saturday getting our asses kicked
by scorpion yep Ellie brings a Mileena and how she
used to rip off her mask to reveal her horrendous
teeth which is one of the most memorable
fatalities from the game but this scene actually
falls from the game it's Angel knives instead
of Mortal Kombat 2 2 we have a cabinet for the
in-universe fighter called the turning and that is
the character Angel knives and Ali describes her
fatality much in the same way that she does
for myelina here would you play this before
you ever play this one I had a friend
who knew everything about this game no
but I had a friend that knew everything about
this game this is one character named Elena who
takes off her mask and she has monster teeth
and then she swallows you whole and Barks out
your bones apparently there's this character
called Angel knives who'd what was it she'd
punch a hole through your stomach before kicking
your head off I'm never a big fan of these things
obviously Warner Brothers on the rights to
Mortal Combat and with him owning HBO as
well they probably gave them that sweet sweet
corporate Synergy deal so we're not registered
talking about this although the original Last
of Us game didn't contain a poster for the game
the Remake did and they obviously released
that look you're not talking about Street
Fighter in the show we'll discuss more on our
super spoiler section how this arcade cabinet
could pop up again so make sure you stay locked
until the end if you've completed the games way
to keep your retail hasn't been out this
way in a couple of years and later on we
discovered that he only went out there once
in the game Joel had never actually been out
of Bill's Town personally so I'm going out there
was a bit of a desperate move Ali heads out into
the back room and you eagle-eyed viewers
might spot a safe code up beside the door
which I Googled to see if it was a code
used in the game unfortunately it's not I
think this is just an Easter egg to the codes
you'd find dotted about the game that would
lead to upgrades and extra ammo in the back Ellie
discovers their own secret with there being a door
basement now in there she finds some things that
you'd normally run into the game like lockers and
filing cabinets with them usually having items
lying in them here we find someone trapped under
the rubble with a fungus growing out of the top
part of their head this is completely grown out
of one of their eyes and as the clicker showed the
cordyceps attached to the brain and then grow up
from there the brain of course controls the body
so doing this allows them to alter our behaviors
and desires once a crowded ended up beating the
eyes and those further along in the infection
chain ended up blind like the clickers are now in
our first video we discussed how the creative team
wanted the infected to seem almost sympathetic
there were times when you'd find them in a
corner subbing away to themselves when you think
about it having a parasite bury its way into your
brain is a horrifying thing to experience this
idea of them being tortured Souls is definitely
apparent yeah I don't think we can show because
of demonetization but Ali Cuts them open and we
see how his flesh has very much become the plant
you know I think that scene actually executed
that well because we haven't come across
anything like that in the show yet where
there's an infected and they're like crying in
the corner and stuff which is a really common
thing to encounter in the video game itself but
with this stalker uh trapped another Rubble there
was something about that for like I was looking up
at her where I was like is Ellie feeling sorry for
this guy because I'm feeling a little bit sorry
for this guy right now even though I know you know
if he's not on the rubble he's just gonna attack
her of course but I did feel that sympathy that
apparently the game developers didn't want you
to somewhat feel for them yeah because whenever
you're playing the game at least from my point
of view I I never felt sympathy whenever I killed
him yeah you feel bad for the human that was once
in there of course but they're no longer I don't
they're no longer that human anymore but yeah no
giving a sympathetic moment to I believe that was
a stalker that was uh that was an interesting
position to uh not only put you know the viewer
there in that moment but also just giving Ellie
her first kill because she'd never experienced
that as well he then takes Mercy on him by
ending his suffering and she also stashes his
assault rifle like I said last week I've always
thought of him more as a pistol and shotgun guy
and with that not being much Emma the wild for
it it's completely pointless carrying it I let
him stashing it here is important and it also
ties into why he doesn't take any of Bill's guns
Joel believes he's returning here and he still
sees Ellie as a job rather than being a person
could have some effect on him and it may end up
changing the way he looks at the world and they
come across a downed plane which Ellie of course
hasn't seen before she's lived her entire life
in the qz and it wasn't exactly Turkish Airlines
promising flights to Gotham this reminded me a lot
of the scene from Steven Spielberg's War of the
Worlds when the characters Ellie is fascinated by
people getting to go up in the sky but Joe points
out the tragedy in it and his life was of course
massively Changed by one the opening of episode 1
had the scientists talking about how disease could
travel fast now due to airplanes and one crash
down taking out Joel Tommy and also Sarah's ride
I dreamed about flying the other night oh yeah
goodbye so I'm on this big plane full of people
and everyone is screaming and yelling because
the plane's going down so I walked the cockpit
opened the door there's no pilot I try to use
the controls but I obviously have no clue how
to fly a plane right before we crash I wake up
I've never been on a plane isn't that weird
overrated well you know dreams are weird now
the meaning of this is difficult to descend do
you think that it gives insight to her character
Ali thought she was a passenger on a plane and
that someone was in control and also guarding
her this could be represented by fedra who raised
her Marlene who was actually looking after her
and then Joel who of course took care of her now
these figures in her life could be representative
of the pilots but I personally think that they
represent the passengers the plane goes crashing
down and this is mirroring the fall of the world
around her she gets up to see there's no pilot
and then this shows that no one is actually in
control and those are the passengers are unable
to fly the plane because no one really knows what
they're doing I think growing up at all kids yeah
they think adults have got their [__] together
and then when they become one they realize that
no one actually knows what's going on which
I think this conversation could be signaling
foreign Ellie asks about how the entire world is
stabilized and she talks about people sitting in
restaurants finding Dandy and then the first bite
happening this was something that we sort of seen
play out last week with a boo Ratner being picked
up by the government in a restaurant before she
was taken to examine a bite victim early bets
it was actually monkeys who spread the disease
and this might be another 28 Days Later don't
they mention that in the game yeah not going
into spoiler territory but there is a reference
in the video game in regards to monkeys which I
won't elaborate further in but if we do reach that
point in the show I'll go more into detail about
that the monkey references a little more it's
the wizard of it's The Wizard of Oz it's the
flying monkeys in just a 28 Days Later reference
never seen it come on Paul I hope you mentioned
in your spoiler section if you don't we got
Andrew here to take you down now what I also
think they could be setting up here is something
coming down the line although we will say before
you know by now for the super spoiler section
that must be it Jill talks about the best theory
for how they managed to spread so easily and this
is something that was also touched upon last week
he correctly guesses that the cordyceps mutated
and they somehow got into the food supply last
week we heard how they changed to the flower
and grain Factory which we discovered acted as
the perfect substrate this in technical terms as I
mean it has specific enzymes that plants can live
on and here a change before spreading out further
if it got into the processing units in the factory
then it could spread into bread and cereal which
would then be eaten by people across the planet
I really hope this notion carries on throughout
the season and I'd love it if we went to a store
and saw the shelves picked there except for the
cereal and bread aisle thank God it didn't infect
the toilet paper because we all know how people
love to grab that now Jill remembers the specific
date it happened which was on a Friday September
26th is because it was of course his birthday but
beyond that it's also day Sarah died a further up
The Path they come across several skeletons the
game would have the odd scene like this with red
and blue clothing standing out amongst the corpses
we never really know what happened at these places
in the game but Joel fills us in on them how much
but the difference here is that they promised
safety at a qz if there wasn't room they'd
take people into the countryside and fire
upon them and I think this scene could be
taking inspiration from the ending of The Great
Escape this is also something that was carried
out in the Holocaust and later on Bill even
describes the government as being Nazis and
the government are all Nazis the government
are all Nazis well yeah now but not then also
with a Great Escape I swear if someone's kicking
off in the comments about spoilers for that I'm
gonna go mental it's been out 60 years I've
never seen it you did spoil it for me though
Paul now Joel says that they were killed so that
they couldn't pass on the infections about why
this was done people rebelled against Federer and
scoring a group like this could potentially lead
to an uprising for example if they promised
safety at the qz and then said you couldn't
come in It's Gonna annoy a lot of people and
it could lead to some backlash and we then
take focus on a rainbow blanket in a child's
body which takes us into our major flashback
for the episode I love how the series has done
this and every episode so far has had a major
part of the past filled in with elements that
weren't present in the game now we've seen what
happened to the survivors days after the outbreak
and this is all new stuff to show us exactly what
it was like X's are painted on doors and in
the game you'd often come across these houses
hidden by hunters that was marked with an X so if
you're playing through the game right now and make
sure you look out for that one every single person
is being given a mandatory evacuation now this and
we see this in front of a civil war Monument along
with fighting against the infected The Last of Us
is also about Man vs Man and this brother versus
brother Monument could be heading towards that
this sign also popped up in the game and when you
entered Lincoln you could spot it in the middle
of the street the irony is they'd actually be
safer in their town as they end up being killed
when they could have lived out the rest of their
lives here in the game you could see how dangerous
Lincoln was due to it being overrun by infected
and here I was kind of thinking I don't know why
John test didn't just stay here Bill kind of
shuts down the idea but it's way better than
the qz and I'm sure that you know a couple more
bottles of wine that I could have convinced him
it was a good idea anyway at this point we're
introduced to Belle played by Nick Offerman we
see him surveilling the tan 3 CCTV and he's very
much an end of the welder actually used to work
with a woman whose son thought doomsday was coming
and apparently spent years collecting tins of
beans little did he know it was toilet roll toilet
roll he needed to horde as their bloody quick now
they really recaptured the look of Belle and along
with his trusted shotgun he looks pretty identical
to the game he's got weapons lining the wall and
collections of guns and I'm a magazine along with
a machete his weapons how he's introduced in the
game with him cutting off the head of an infected
that's got Joel on the ground he ends up Dunning
his gas mask which he also wore in that and we see
his bunkers cleverly located beneath the chest of
drawers without seeing the gas masks back which is
something he too worn the PlayStation counterpot
as we know those spores have been removed from the
series do the Creative team worrying that everyone
would be asking why they aren't constantly done in
gas masks again I don't think people would have
wanted it could have also been for the budget or
to see the actors faces as they're terrified by
the infected later on we also see this room has
a workbench in it he's pulled directly from the
game and they're what players use to upgrade their
weapons also forgot to mention last week that we
actually had another nod to the game when Tess
and Joel went into their backpack they swung them
off their shoulders and got on the ground found
it just like how Joel does every time he wants to
craft something true there's also the magazines
that we see throughout the episode in the game
these were used for upgrade trees and they helped
you unlock special skills Gotta Love little Easter
eggs like that where the way it's even being
played like Joe getting on the ground and putting
it down you're so in the moment it's so subtle
they're not even registered like oh that's like
how he does it in the game yeah I mean there's
been plenty of times I feel like throughout these
three episodes where we've had moments like that
we're like the guitar ah there's that but yeah
there are other moments where you know we get
someone amazing like Paula to point out no it's
there's the backpack moments like oh my goodness
they were so subtle about it I didn't even realize
but again you just saw in the moment I love the uh
the upgrade like right when I saw that one I did
notice but yeah I'm just again the attention to
detail on this show and I'm glad they got Neil
druckman to work on this but it's gray day now
as Bill comes out of the ground we can also see
that he has a wine rack and you're ready to wind
stolletta showing how much it means to him when he
serves a bottle to Frank prank is played by Murray
Bartlett and you might recognize him as playing
Armand in the White Lotus he's a completely
opposite Bell and we can see this in many ways
bill is kind of out of shape and this is seen
later on when the pair go jogging together this
actually speaks to their time in the apocalypse as
Bill's been kicking his feet up and living it up
or as Frank has been fighting to survive out there
it's pretty much survival of the fittest meanwhile
Bill's in a safe place where it's 1.40ish per
gallon of gas bring on the poster box take me
there take me back seriously now we see that
Bella's door has an accident with markings around
it like the one before these are pulled from the
game but they've also appeared in real life and
during Hurricane Katrina they could be found on
doors these to note how many are inside which team
search did and the date that they did we can also
see that Bell's House was built circus 1793 which
makes it from pre-civil War era this further adds
to his old school Persona and how he doesn't
trust the government he's a regular old one
anyway the town is completely empty now and
we get a sort of last man on Earth situation
with them basically being able to do what
he wants it is funny because while he's not
playing Ron Swanson he is playing this certain
way like this could have been Ron Swanson in
the apocalypse there's versions of have you
seen Parks and Recreation never watched that
the only clip I've ever seen from that show
is the one uh the Kim Kardashian joke that
Chris Pratt made on the outtake everyone loves
a good comeback story right Kim Kardashian in
the video she gets she gets corner back I
think oh have you seen that yeah that's a
very funny joke well let me try to contribute to
the video then while you do that whatever this is
yeah Francois there's even an episode of Ron
Swanson it's a very anti-government there's a
whole episode where he's trying to go off the
grid but he is like free from the government
and everything by the beginning this could have
been Ron Swanson in here but this is not the same
kind of character so you're saying Neil druckman
watched Parks and Rec and went that's bill yeah
in some ways montages like this are a staple
of post-apocalyptic movies and most famously
I remember the one from the Dawn of the Dead it
went on a shopping spree in the mall but it's also
something that popped up in 28 Days Later with
them going into the supermarket and just going
well with all the food now this is to the backdrop
of the song yes I'm Coming Home by Fleetwood Mac
it makes it really a beat and I think the entire
point of Bella's story is a show that you can have
fun and find love even in the apocalypse Tess
and y'all were a couple but they never really
seemed like they were in love and instead I
think the apocalypse pushed them together so
they had safety in numbers Joel has completely
shut himself off and to me the stuff with Bill
and Frank could be a reflection of how he needs to
open up a bell takes a speed boat fills up several
barrels of petrol and goes while at Home Depot
this is to build his traps which we didn't end up
in carrying in the game when you first entered
Lincoln normally you'd be walking along would
notice a tripwire which you'd then have to set
off either by luring in an infected or throwing
a brick at it when he handed his home and I love
dropping these things throughout the game you know
just a little trick for them now an infected setup
one later by pulling a trap by it and bill says it
doesn't get all you're definitely right and yeah
take me back to that game and the first thing he
does is secure the area get some alcohol and build
a generator to power the town he's created a nice
little life for himself and it's during this time
that he ends up meeting Frank a bill really was
someone who was used to being alone and people
who prepare for the apocalypse tend to do so by
themselves it's rarely a group ever because it
requires paranoia and shutting oneself off in
order to survive Frank shows that he should open
up to people though and if it wasn't for him then
he'd never know Tess and Joe four years later
we hear the song White Room by Cream which has
a lot of meaning that applies to the episode the
song is about someone stuck in a white room by
themselves and here they face depression and also
loneliness bill of course as a White House and is
submerged by most of the buildings he's walled
himself up from everything and now he's alive
he's not really living for anything this reminds
me a lot of Alexandria from The Walking Dead but
there's no other people around and therefore it's
not really the rest of civilization and the homie
is a poster for don't tread on me and this also
brings a lot of meaning with it Not only was it a
Metallica song but it was also a political slogan
used in the American Revolution the dates all the
way back to the Bible and in Latin the phrase is
Noli me Tangier this means do not touch me and
it was said by Jesus to marry Magdalene after
his resurrection the bomb between physical and
spiritual was at its highest during this point
and it came across more as a warning to it I
think it's more aligned with a Metallica song as
it's the same as the cover that was used and that
song Had lyrics like Give me liberty give me death
a rattlesnake imagery yeah Benjamin Franklin who
said that the animal was a great symbol for the
American Spirit anyway a trap is triggered and out
in the Holy dug Bell finds Frank believing it's
its own trap bill is immediately suspicious and
in the game it was difficult to not immediately
have paranoia when he came across someone you I
do really appreciate whenever you go out of your
way to point out thematically what some of these
more production design details ultimately entail
because you know I love the idea of like diving
further in and that adds further more to who this
person is as a character and the world that they
inhabited even before the apocalypse and what
dictates them for where they're at now so I think
that's actually pretty cool to have some type of
symbolism like that there that if you were to read
into it you'd find out oh this actually is a very
specifically chosen thing because you're like all
right yeah we'll build like classic rock makes
sense but there's a Metallica poster right there
then you find out oh this is why this character
would have this one there that's something that
like people who develop games really think about
it so have that here in the show itself I think
is actually a really nice nugget that should not
be overlooked the don't tread on me I mean I agree
with everything you just said but the other point
where he was mentioning you know the don't touch
me kind of thing I always felt that was more of
in Bill's personality too from what we remember
in the video game where like remember how freaked
out and crazy he would get on Ellie whenever she
would touch anything invade any of his personal
space or belongings kind of felt like it was kind
of both ways on that he says that he set out
from Baltimore qz which we learn is now more
now we never visit this location in the game where
the characters instead heading more in a Northern
direction of Pittsburgh according to Google Maps
it's a six day walk non-stop between Baltimore
and Boston so we can see why Frank's lost so many
out in the road Bill decides to take him in and
this all happens after using a scanner to get the
all clear now they have dinner together and Bill
ends up feeding him rabbit these were animals
the characters had to hunt in the game because
obviously yeah the farm industry is gone it's
complete opposite to what he's just gone through
and the man's been out on the road facing in death
and I was sipping wine and eating rabbit he takes
to the piano and here he plays a song a long long
time by Linda ronstad this contains lyrics like I
can see I'm gonna love you for a long long time
which is something he sounds terrible too you
sound terrible mate you sound terrible but it does
play in the episode now Bill takes to it instead
Annie manages to sing it perfectly it kinda sums
up the pair I think with one being chaotic Razia
there is highly ordered in control the lyrics
of course the relationship that they're about
to be in and for the next 45 minutes we see the
rest of their lives play out bill is different
in the game I think because he's way more open or
as in the last diversity he looks down on Joe for
caring about people and in this world that sort
of shit's good for one thing getting you killed
so you know what it did wasn't the [__]
up and I realized it's got to be just me
we never really see his relationship with
Frank and I have spoken to people who play
the game without even picking up on it at all
Frank wasn't ever something about this episode
in juxtaposition of that completely develops
their relationship now it is of course share
similarities with his game counterpart like
how he kicks off about Resource Management why
he does that in the final letter too and we
find out that he's the one who reached out to
Tess and Joel they come over for a garden party
and Bell's thesis is a bad idea further diving
into how close stuff he is from Humanity he brings
a gun to the dinner table and Joel says we can't
help each other and get that gun out of my face
this of course goes beyond just being cautious
and the pair of course both ready to flip at a
moment's notice if this situation calls for it I
left alone and Joel offers to get more material
to make the fence last the rest of their lives
together in the game it was clear Tess was more
the point of contact which is why Joel will never
visited Lincoln personally a test and Frank talk
about using the radio again but they decide to use
a code in case anyone's listening in as we know
from episode 1 this becomes the 60s 70s and 80s
music which also plays in what they discover
at the end now Jill warns that Raiders will
eventually swarm the town and after Frank makes a
strawberry garden we see this playing out in the
night reminded me a lot of I Am Legend and keeping
out Raiders is something that's too mirrored in
the game moving through linking and you actually
only ever encounter the infected because Bill's
got such a tight leash on everything after being
shot Bell tiles Frank to call Joel as he's someone
like him who's able to take care of weaker people
this is of course why he was entrusted with Ellie
and we very much have this Dynamic of a strong
Survivor protecting a weaker less equipped one
Bell survives though and in a twist of fate Frank
is left in the wheelchair who then jump to 2023
and finally catch up with the present both are in
their winter years now and we can see that Frank
has spent a lot of time painting this is important
too as it shows that the better side of humanity
like art and agriculture haven't died out in the
desperation he's trying to paint bill but Judo
using his motor functions he now can't do it what
about we do close out with a painting of him which
pretty much sums up the love of his life now these
really subtle moments like Bill giving a wing to
Frank as he paints him and watering the flowers
for the last time and at this point you could be
forgiven for thinking where not even in a zombie
apocalypse show Bill wakes up find that Frank has
decided this will be his last day but rather than
wallowing in it they decide to make the most of
it the pair get married and have dinner together
and Frank wants to take his pills that he can fade
away into the night hear the song on the nature
of daylight and having just covered [__] Island
in arrival for the channel I think the creative
team were inspired by those two films both use the
piece with I think probably the latter lending
itself better to what's going on here I'd only
get two spoilery on it but the end of the movie
is about embracing the beauty of life no matter
how heartbreaking it is which is also reflected
in this scene as well the pair have what could be
a very painful day ahead of them but instead
they're using it as a way to celebrate their
life without dwelling on the sadness of death that
we're all gonna face one day yeah I think that's a
really solid point because the last of us world is
one that often you think about it like it's such
a bleak world it's so dark and you know it is
such an interesting subversion with a character
like Bill if you know the game because Bill is
one of the most hardened Ruthless People and
counter the furthest thing from welcoming right
while that's capturing the show you see this
Evolution they still find like the purpose to
live the experience the memories that they are
able to generate together over time and that's
part of the the glory of watching an episode
like this is even in the darkest of times they
managed to find light through human connection
with one another I find that to be such a rare
thing to explore in an apocalypse story I mean
while that that can often be there but for that
to be like a focus of a whole episode tell such
a classic beautiful tale of two people falling in
love creating a life together of protecting each
other serving each other but also making each
other laugh all this time it was so unexpected
for this show and to also do that for Bill but I
thought it worked perfectly even as a fan of the
game I thought we're perfectly yeah and also to
add on to just personality traits from abilities
very paranoid in the game as well as well as
we saw earlier on in this episode I think the
thing I love the most to a lot of what you were
just saying is the emotional depth we got in the
character and both characters rather in the
relationship the way we got to see it I just
love the way how they the the separation of time
like it was just done very well like just getting
to see their relationship Blossom and then again
in such a bleak post-apocalyptic World which is
obviously the worst of times like something
beautiful can spiral out of that as well and
again it's probably gonna cause interesting debate
after this episode because it didn't follow the
game specifically and obviously we didn't get you
know the Ellie and uh bill skirmishes which I'm
a sucker for but I think this episode you know
had a very beautiful theme and message that I
deeply appreciated in we still got the version
of the game so that's good with that but again
this was so satisfying to watch that it doesn't
bother me that we didn't get an exact replica of
what happened in the game so but I'm very curious
to see how the response is going to be yeah first
of all positive yeah for sure Bill and reveals
that he's decided to go out with Frank rather
than continue living now this is a complete 180
on his original feelings when when the outbreak
first happened whereas originally he wanted to
survive by himself here we see that he's grown
to the point he'd rather not live if it meant he
lost Frank at this point we hear a song from the
game that also happens at an emotional moment
in it we'll talk about this later on in the
super spoiler section see that's the other thing
is I I love his as a character like bill before
the apocalypse was such a lonely person who
dejected the very thought of connecting with
people he has that line in the in the game in
the show of like I was never scared until I
met you I love the irony of how he didn't find a
true connection until most people were wiped out
yeah like it's there's something very ironic about
that I think that's that's a beautiful story but
it's very much used in the context to show that
not everything is Bleak I think he kind of need
this moment to breathe in a show like this as
The Last of Us it can be pretty depressing so
it's nice to have this balance of like look there
is still some good I only enjoy either Lincoln to
find the flowers starting to die and the food on
the table has started mold she plays some notes
on the piano echoing the earlier scene and finds
a letter which mirrors the one from the game yeah
though it's a lot more positive without Landing
their lives together we learned they laid down
and went to sleep and again I got some flashes of
28 Days Later in that gym goes home to discover
his parents have done something similar but they
showed it there whereas a letter wants them not to
go into the bedroom now it's addressed directly to
Joe and bill says that though he hated the world
there was one person worth saving he's talking
about Tessier but now that position has of course
shifted Ellie who he's gonna go on protecting we
get a focus on the sentence about keeping tests
safe which is pretty devastating because gels of
course failed to do this instead of confronting
the grief though he immediately leaves and takes
his mind off it by crumpling up the ladder just
in the same way that this get a scene in which
they discovered the truck and left at the front
Joe also checks the fridge which has sulfuric acid
in it Jill asks to see her arm and this could be
teasing at somehow we'll discuss so no spoilers
because I'll get i'll get tons of comments but
super small section now in the basement we
discover why there was 80's music playing on
the radio at the end of episode one Bill had it
set up so that if he didn't reset the countdown
then it was just gonna play 80s constantly on a
loop this would of course signal that they were
in danger and we'll get Tess and Gerald to come
out to where they were now it is possible that
Bell knew this would happen anyway which is why
he of course addressed the letter Joel I do have
a quick Through Time new Time new time so Joe and
Tess they'd been searching desperately for a car
battery so that they could get to Tommy originally
in the game they sell guns to Robert but the whole
thing in the show revolved around getting a
battery for a truck bill of course has one and
I think that he might have had the 80s music on
Loop so that they were gonna come out looking for
him he left down the keys for the truck because
he possibly knew that they needed one and thus
this is very much his last bill and testament to
get them with the ride that they've been looking
for anyway that's in a few times and we can
see Ellie sorry you have to let that [Music]
sorry I have to let it play out
right as I was saying you don't it's gonna be
stuck in my head for a while as I was saying the
pair get some clothes and Ellie slips into the
red t-shirt that she wore throughout the game
she also finds a handgun and I believe it's the
same model as the one she carries in the source
material Jill gives it to her a nap but here she
takes it behind his back which might cause some
issues later on she all comes out finally wearing
the green checkered shirt that he does throughout
the majority of this story and you might have
noticed Frank wearing this earlier in the episode
they're getting the car together and originally in
the game he had a much tensor scene in which you
had to jump start it Jill and Bill had to push it
as the infected sworn whilst Ellie sat in the ride
attempting to pop the clutch love the little touch
of her not knowing to wear a seatbelt and together
they head out as she discovers the tape in the
glove box no points for guessing what the song
is and we watch them right out to Linda ronsten's
long long time we close out to an open window with
a picture of Bill hanging up which takes us into
our super super spoiler section I was thinking
this now for this bit I will be talking about
elements that appear in both games they don't end
it well one of them's an ending rooner but there
are some moments in Easter eggs in the episode
that will probably spoil things down the line here
at this point I'd really love you guys if you hit
the thumbs up on the way out and make sure you
subscribe to not miss our breakdowns in episode
4. thanks right what a [__] [__] I play their
games well they're bloody hell is wrong with you
anyway the open window has a lot of big moments
in the game it's the menu screen for the first one
and in part two it's also the last shot as Ellie
walks away that summed up the end of her story and
here it's very much summing up the ending of Bill
and Frank's a Mortal Kombat 2 cabinet is pretty
important as well and I think it's something
that's going to return in the series later on
it ties in massively with the writing story and
in the DLC left behind you played on the Turning
cabinet alongside Riley my guess is that they'll
do something similar on the Riley flashback
and have them imagining what it's like to play
Mortal Kombat 2 wasting money getting their asses
monkey and how she bets that they spread the
cordyceps monkeys actually show up in the game
how we end up encountering them when we enter
the university turns out the fireflies were
experimenting on them to find a cure to them being
so close to us on a DNA level might not have been
a connection to that but with monkeys potentially
appearing down the line I thought I'd bring that
line up it better be some [__] monkeys it
could also be something as well with that
being administered in the series in part two when
Ellie and Dina bunker down she ends up showing her
her arm we discover that Ellie did a chemical burn
on the bite using sulfuric acid and this was then
covered up with a tattoo once it healed Ellie
got sick of constantly having to hide her arm
so she carried this out once it became clear that
The Cure thing wasn't gonna oh yeah you get what
could be a nod to the spaceship scene in that a
thousand people he talks about the car being like
a spaceship and in part two she all takes le2
museum for her birthday and then Ellie imagines
what it's like traveling into space anyway that
wraps up the breakdown and I think this episode
kind of transcended the Apocalypse to tell a
love story this is something that's been at the
heart of the show and in the official podcast for
episode 1 they said that the show was very much
going to be discussing the positives and negatives
of Love yeah it's a more wholesome Outlook but in
the case of Joel and Ali we see how dangerous it
is Joel begins to love Ellie like she's his own
daughter and because of this he Dooms Humanity
by killing the fireflies in order to save her
life so we have this idea that love can be a good
thing but also that it has its negatives as well
especially if someone stands in the way of it I
think this was important to explore with Bill and
Frank and it'll probably massively influence
the future episodes even if it's not obvious
now it's a big deviation from the game so whether
people prefer that or not is gonna be something I
think they're gonna be going back and forth over
I think this stuff in the game works better as a
level because you travel through the graveyard the
school and then you fight a blower in it kind of
rams up to your boss which I think works in a game
and the show kinda really needed to do something
different so they focused on character development
gave us a bit of a breather so it wasn't all doom
and gloom and they also managed to make one
of the side characters way more fleshed out I
enjoyed it and so far I think we've had three
really really strong episodes I know there's
kind of back and forth at the moment but let me
know your thoughts below and again thank you for
rocking with me of course thank you and thank
you for getting the three times three times
three times stuck in my head yeah but that was
great video I mean so much of this show yeah of
course exploring the positives and negatives
of Love is an everlasting theme in The Last
of Us uh it's so prevalent throughout both of the
games we can have our muddied interpretations of
what we do for love and in the Name of Love what
consequences that can lead down so yeah I think
that's a a great thing to constantly be exploring
and to make it such a something that's really on
the surface for audiences to really attain to
obviously the monkey reference I made earlier
that was obviously the one I was making yeah yeah
but uh no I agree with everything you said and I
also agree with Paul I think again I love that
they this episode took a little more of a slow
burn just getting more fleshed out with these
characters especially a character like Bill who's
not fleshed out in the game in any other way other
than we know a few character traits and just that
he's really hard sure and that kind of thing but
like to get me this emotionally vested in in such
a side character that I just thought was you know
just a hard ass badass type of character in the
side character in the video game I just I thought
it was a really smart move for for the TV show and
again the levels play out better in the game but
this plays out better in the TV show so I thought
it was again A very wise and smart decision to do
at the end of the day you actually technically get
more bill in the show more than you do in the game
it's just you're you're playing levels with bills
so it feels like you might have more bill but
that's not the case you get way more story on
Bill here than you do at all in the game so yeah
and the characters yeah way more fleshed out I
mean you get obvious basically action sequences
with Bill in the video game whereas here you get
a lot more character development with I think
one action sequence and I gotta say too really
quick before we let this go we probably talked
about in our reaction video I absolutely loved
that scene that they had with the four of them at
the table right and just little character traits
where pills got the like his hand on the trigger
while he's eating yeah like I'm like that is just
so Bill like just the paranoia so bill so bill um
but yeah uh no that was a great episode and also
to the makeup that they did with anatova with
Tess like just making her look so much younger
and then also how the Aged out Bill and Frank is
just all around just a great episode phenomenal
stuff phenomenal work heavy spoilers you're
becoming a super wealthy rich man with these
videos and I'm happy to see it happen to one of
the best guys I know out there guys subscribe to
heavy spoilers if you haven't done so already and
hey let's send this with shouting out hey thanks
for joining me here John oh no problem Rachel
Reardon you got a great song out there danger
Jeffrey Robinson danger she didn't he never heard
that before real in the Joss save myself Barca fan
101 my my favorite kind of lounge chair Roberto
Angela man you did damn Angelo 10 Downing Street
Ian decastica Neil Simon Shanghai Noon
Shanghai Jacob Neptune Kayla the cop oh King the
Conqueror Kelly King Mitchell Reed Richards no
more boobs all Anne Ling James Howlett burden
I wanna get a bureau with Kira Eric Khan's 39.
doesn't like to do 69s the football number
because YouTube's weird goosey-goosey dance
in the batuci nick triple x uh Ice Cube one
long two Gory for YouTube uh Gail weathers
Craig Ferguson Mohammed is the most commonly
used name on Earth Al sharani Jaron big wanner
stiff Cliff Rodriguez Aaron Michael Myers
Master Thief John the goat big boat full of hoes
Tron magic Infinity Jared Leto let's do it it's
a disaster when you're around Lorenzo Baxter but
really it's not it makes life go faster nothing
is plain when you're chilling with differently
sane Marco tunn still loves to kill oh look out
use the force Lauren American Horse simply faded
is uh not the name of a chili pepper song that is
so much faded Joanna Banna of bobana Saint Luigi
Rogue Willy slow jam 94. Justin
Cartman pour me a glass of Rose
you got it Rachel oh bro Alden Aaron wreck
semi-calling Phillips screwdriver Junior Jen
and the Holograms Smith Melody committing a
felony while drinking a Hennessy in public
alrighty guys thank you so much for being part
of our patreon page and showing that support it
means the world to have you here it's uh one of
the best ways to help keep this channel afloat
so thank you for being here again hope to see at
least 99 of you in February if one of you goes
that's fine but no more than one but
there can only be one if you leave you
gotta find a replacement yes Ms the rules
all right watch this video conclude [Music]